pour moi pour nous lecteurs oui bah oui
bon d'accord
voilà la conclusion de cet agent de
l'urssaf elle vient de contrôler le
conducteur de cet utilitaire dirigeant
d'une entreprise de btp il est
soupçonnée d'employer une personne non
déclarés présente à ses côtés lors du
contrôle j'ai deux gérants qui est
contrôlé qui prend dizaine de camions et
j'ai aussi deux passagers
donc il a déclaré qu'il travaille
[Musique]
on va contrôler les utilitaires donc les
chauffeurs à savoir s'ils sont déclarés
et éventuellement les accompagnent les
accompagnants ont voir effectivement
aussitôt s'ils sont déclarés l'objectif
c'est de déceler si la personne elle est
déclarée et du coup voir si lé travail
légal ou pas urssaf mais aussi caisse
primaire d'assurance maladie des
yvelines était présente sur cette vaste
opération de contrôle sur l'air de repos
de morainvilliers les deux enquêteurs de
l'assurance maladie ont en charge le
contrôle des véhicules de transports
sanitaires ont vérifié la bonne
facturation des prestations par les
transporteurs sanitaires dans le cadre
à l'assurance maladie c'est pour éviter
la facturation d'actes fictif
éventuellement des équipages qui sont
pas agréés au niveau de la rs connu dans
n'aurait dans deux repaires soir à
l'initiative de cette opération de
contrôle la police aux frontières de la
grande couronne pour elle sa mission
lutter contre l'immigration irrégulière
nous ciblons principalement des
camionnettes de type de chantier qui
sont susceptibles
de conduire des personnes en situation
irrégulière sur des sites tenus par des
entreprises dans le domaine du btp ou
autre plusieurs enquêteurs de la brigade
mobile de recherche sont mobilisés en
appui des agents de la cellule de
fraudes documentaires et à l'identité
pour débusquer les usurpations les
agents utilisent une loupe portative ou
un microscope
par exemple j'aime être sur marine afin
de crayon ça permet en fait d'aller voir
si le mode d'impression est bien celui
prévu par le pays donc là on peut
vraiment voir le détail de lancre voir
comment elle est donc là on voit que
paparazzi tire pas de bavure concernant
la brigade mobile de recherche de la
police aux frontières des yvelines une
dizaine de personnes travaillent dans
cette unité en 2021 elles ont effectué
117 contrôle dont 51 se sont avérés
positifs